je pense que tous les collègues qui
travaillent dans des quartiers où il ya
une majorité des musulmans soient
habitués à voir toutes les deux secondes
dans une classe 1 ou l' instar foula qui
vient comme ça mais en plus c'est pas
dit avec provocation c'est ça le pire ça
veut dire que les élèves ne ne se
rendent même pas compte qu'ils disent
que moi j'ai des élèves qui vient du 20e
une belle émission qui s'appelle genèse
et où j'ai déjà les ventes d élèves qui
viennent du maghreb qui me dit lassé
stealth yeux je sais mon passage des
loisirs ou là parce que les autres ils
sont pas tous musulmans et je leur dis
bah oui vous avez raison parce que c'est
une question de politesse et quand je
dis au jour par les condamnés seraient
gérés aux les sujets qui sont aussi
impossibles à aborder ou difficiles à
aborder ses seins parce que sinon ça
c'est jonathan a tant choqué en ce jeu
là c'est un succès je pense que l'on
parle d'une langue arabe et vous et vous
l'a confondue avec la religion ce moment
donné si ce qui choque m'enseigne
intérêts sur la chaleur d'un style kebab
je pense qu'elle a eu
aménageur de lettres a été pris au piège
par les jours d'abord où là évidemment
de six musulmans parce que les arabes
chrétiens disent pas voulu là d'accord
on passe sur ce que c'est d'être moderne
sur ce que n'avait pas la modernité de
la série à succès c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit qu'on passait à est ce qu'il ya des
choses aussi monde a difficile à aborder
qui est le véritable moi je vais là cela
peut pas moi je veux pas prendre une
langue en faire une religion
musulman ça c'est pas la question de la
langue arabe j'aime beaucoup la reverra
pas le sujet c'est ben oui alors je
pense au la tulipe quoi je pense au
contraire
[Applaudissements]
vous dites n'importe et ouest à la barbe
études houle
j'aimerais qu'on reste un sujet chaud
voilà j'ai fait une grosse pointure
demain je pense que non mais justement
sur rodrigues je prends sur le ton de la
blague alors c'est quelque chose
d'important parce que justement je pense
que tout peut être discutée que les
élèves à condition d'avoir c'est vrai le
tact je ne dis pas que c'est facile
chaque fois qu un attentat ou quand il
ya un mois j'ai déjà fait mes élèves
quant à lui le bataclan cats et on peut
discuter tout il faut avoir le tact et
le courage de l'aborder ce qui n'est pas
facile parce que quand l'institution
vous suis pas sur ces questions là
messieurs parce que vous regardez là les
hommages à semer le pâtis c'est pas
enfin on a dit monsieur le ministre a
rapporté que ça avait été fait partout
dans un certain nombre d'établissements
mois les échos que j'ai eus des
collections si la tribune c'est qu'en
réalité il y avait eu très peu dommage
parce que les collègues avaient peur
parce qu'il sentait pas soutenu et parce
que l'établissement de ne pas l'exemple
je vous nomme envoyer des rapports
d'inspection où il y avait écrit dessus
noir sur blanc ceci n'est pas l'occasion
d'une mémoire accès mais le parti a pâti
ce n'est pas l'occasion de rappeler les
faits qui se sont passés c'est
l'occasion d'avoir un débat sur la lys
et une séquence bidon et revenir sûr que
vous venez de dire il ya un certain
nombre d'établissements ou de classe qui
n'ont pas osé organiser cet hommage ou
sept heures de mémoire envoyé j'avais
des ailes aux professeurs pour dire
organiser le d'accord non sur les
minorités y en a quelques-uns bien sûr
mais la majorité soit ils ont peur soit
ils se censure alors même ils se font
violence du point de vue de leur idéal
républicain du point de vue de leur
idéal de la laïcité et moi je trouve
justement que c'est à nouveau un juste
parce qu'en réalité c'est aussi
considéré que ces élèves là ne méritent
pas de recevoir une tradition française
qui a permet pourtant de faire des
français d'où qu'il vienne même
tradition
excusez moi un outil important pour les
professeurs je pense que vous en
conviendrez c'est le fait que la loi
dans notre pays il a notamment la loi du
29 juillet 1881 sur la liberté de la
presse n'accepte pas les injures
racistes et les injures à caractère
homophobe un antisémite et que c'est que
la seule proposition que j'ai entendu de
la part de votre candidat pour l'instant
en la matière c'est qu'il faut que
supprimer ces injures là que les cds
l'ina
mais nous répondrons
ils vont venir
mais on me dit rien sur l'éducation bien
sûr il est balisé la tribune des
professeurs
et et je vous promets je m'envole
d'occasion seront également proposés par
zemmour puisque zemmour réellement mais
ces départs zemmour s'est bien amusé
mort y
apposer ses insultes je pense un élève
que j'ai eu il ya quelques années
immigrés mamadou qui n'ont les parents
ne savaient pas et par les français ni
même écrit français qui à dauphine
aujourd'hui parce qu'il reste encore
aujourd'hui une école républicaine qu'on
est en train de détruire
mon rythme et c'est pour ça moi que je
suis loyal envers mes réponses mamadou
et je vous réaffirme a compris parce que
ce sont mes el meselha j'aurai à les
dire et je vois bien ce que voulait dire
quand vous dites très bien autorités moi
je vous dis je veux que mes élèves
puissent continuer à réussir je vais
voir une classe à l'état pur les écoles
chez les verts